it's like when you leave disney you're
meant to like turn the page
we've seen countless stars shed the
disney reputation
and we're pretty sure dove cameron is
well on her way to becoming her own
person
cameron has not only moved past disney
roles
but is branched out to a variety of
ventures which
tragic life event contributed to her
passionate advocacy work
we're taking a look at all the performer
has done and what's to come in this
exciting career of hers
it was actually really embarrassing i
was like she's gonna hate me
dove cameron is unique among the disney
child stars since she didn't rise to
fame until a bit later in her life
while she was still a teenager she was
17 and had already done some tv and film
roles in notable shows like shameless
and the mentalist
the disney channel series liv and maddie
brought the actress into the disney
mainstream and led to further projects
with a franchise like descendants
he was painting all of my magic with the
ember and i felt
all of my power slipping away cameron
successfully brought two distinct and
entertaining characters to life in liv
and maddie
this being her first disney gig
definitely set her apart as a star
and the world could recognize her
discipline and skill so
you know how i played both liv and
maddie since she's begun
moving away from the disney world and
establishing her own name in the
industry
she's taken on surprisingly varied and
diverse roles
cameron has proven her discipline and
skill range since she's moved into
performing in musicals
she's already got four big musical parts
under her belt
and a musical tv series on the way when
she hasn't been rehearsing for a stage
show
she's spent time in the marvel world
bringing more mature roles to life in
agents of shield and the animated series
marble rising
we're looking forward to her shedding
her disney reputation even more
in grittier parts in the upcoming
psychological thriller isaac
and bj novak's horror thriller vengeance
while many child actors don't have the
best history with disney and are trying
to move forward from that time in their
career
cameron has said that she has always had
a very positive relationship with disney
and felt she had a lot of freedom
making her transition into different
roles much easier
in fact rather than disney putting any
pressure the performer has found the
expectations of the public more
difficult to deal with
disney channel had to like figure out
how they were gonna break the news to me
since she's a brilliant musical theater
actress it's no surprise that she's
branched her music career out further as
well
the venture has been a major contributor
to cameron shedding her disney channel
reputation
as it not only allows her to take on a
greater variety of roles
but to grow her own voice as a musician
and artist
music helped me as a medium to kind of
understand myself and where i was in my
life
the style and approach she's taken with
her music has allowed her to redefine
her image and find her own sound and
voice
inspired by music that doesn't sound
like the rest
the multidisciplinary artist has said
she doesn't feel like she's
quite found her sound yet and believes
it's too early in her career and life to
know what that would be
but she is definitely well on her way
the fact that she writes all her own
songs in addition to singing
definitely contributes to her growth as
a person her music
is raw intimate and full of exciting
energy which has been bringing her to
the attention of those who may not have
followed her disney journey
her recent songs waste so good
and we belong have been well received
and are definitely
not what we thought we'd be hearing from
the live and maddie actress
we're looking forward to hearing more as
her voice and taste grows
i mean i do love the lyric maybe i just
woke up on the right side of my empty
bed
[Music]
dove cameron's upbringing was far from
easy and has definitely affected the
causes she cares about and the way she
lives now
she tragically lost her father when she
was a teenager
and has struggled with eating disorders
anxiety and depression
a journey which she has been very open
about on social media
her outspokenness about mental health
has been a big step away from the idea
of a perfect disney star
but it hasn't made her any less popular
her honesty and advocacy have made her a
big inspiration
and a positive role model for young
people to look to
because i am so anxious i have a bit of
a fear of like being vulnerable in the
industry
cameron regularly shares the details of
her anxiety and depression symptoms
allowing her to connect with fans and
raise awareness of mental illness
in addition to her honesty her providing
of self-care tools and positive messages
online
has made her a unique celebrity with a
refreshing outlook
all of which are major contributors to
her ongoing success and growth as an
artist
and inspiration for this generation dove
cameron is so much more than just a
talented actress
so we have a feeling her career is only
just beginning
which aspect of cameron's career are you
most excited by
what role are you most looking forward
to seeing her do let us know in the
comments
make sure you hit that like button and
subscribe so you don't miss
a single one of our videos
you